we asked about averages all the time and
in the context of random variables
averages get abstracted into a lovely
concept called the expectation of the
Wren variable let's begin with a
motivating example which as is often the
case will come from gambling so there's
a game that's actually played in casinos
called carnival dice where you have
three dice and you're the way you play
is you pick your favorite number from
one to six whenever it happens to be and
then you roll the three dice the dice
are soon to be fair so each one of them
has a one in six chance of coming up
with any given number and then the
payoff goes as follows for every match
of your favorite number you get $1 and
if none of your favorite no if none of
the die show your favorite number then
you lose $1 okay let's do an example
suppose your favorite number was five
you announced that to the to the house
of the dealer and then the die start
rolling now if your roll happened to
come up with the numbers two three and
four while there's no fives there so
you've lost $1 on the other hand if your
rolls came out five four six there's one
five you've won $1 if it came out five
four five there's two fives you've won
$1 and if was all five you've actually
won $3 now real carnival vices often
played where either win or lose a dollar
depending on whether there's any match
at all but we're playing a more generous
game where if you double match you get
$2 if you triple match you get $3 so the
basic question about this is is this a
fair game is this worth playing and how
can we think about that well we're going
to think about it probabilistically so
let's think about the probability of
rolling no fives if five is my favorite
number what's the probability that I
roll none of them well there's a five
out of six chance that I don't roll a
five on the first die and on the second
day and on the third die and since the
die rolls are assumed to be independent
that dies are independent the
probability of no fives is five six to
the third which comes out to be 125 two
hundred and sixteenths I'm writing this
out because we're gonna
all the numbers over 216 to make them
easier to compare ok what's the
probability of 1/5
well the probability of any single
sequence of die rolls with a single 5 is
5/6 of no 5 times 5/6 of no 5 times 1/6
of 1/5 and there are 3 choose 1 possible
sequences of dice rolls with 1 5 and the
others non 5s
likewise for two 5s there's 3 choose 2
times 5 6 2 the one on which is one way
of choosing the place that does not have
a 5 and 1/6 times 1/6 which is the
probability of getting fives in the
other places I didn't say that well but
you can get it straight okay the
probability of three fives is the
probability of 1/6 of getting a 5 on the
first die 1/6 of getting a 5 on the
second die 1/6 of getting a 5 on the
third die simply 1 6 cubed ok so we can
easily calculate these probabilities
this is a familiar exercise let's put
them in a chart so what we figured out
is that 0 matches has a probability of
125 over 216 and in that case I lose a
buckle one match turns out to have a
probability of 75 out of 216 and I win
$1 two matches is 15 out of 216 I win $2
and three matches there's one chance in
216 that I win the $3 ok so now I can
ask about um what do I expect to win
suppose I play 216 games and the games
split exactly according to these
probabilities then what I would expect
is that I would wind up with 0 matches
about a hundred and twenty-five times
that was the probability of there being
no matches there was 125 216 so if I
play 216 games I expect about 125 we're
gonna I'm gonna win nothing or I'm gonna
get no matches which actually means I'll
lose $1 on each one match I expect about
75 times two matches 15 times 3 matches
once
so my average when is gonna be a hundred
and twenty-five times - 175 times 115
times 2 plus 1 times 3 divided by 216 so
these numbers on the top were have the
616 roll split among my choices of
losing a dollar winning a dollar winning
two dollars in winning three dollars and
it comes out to be slightly negative
it's actually minus eight cents minus
217 216 of a dollar which is about minus
eight cents so I'm losing on the average
eight cents per roll this is not a fair
game it's really biased against me and
if I keep playing long enough I'm gonna
find that I average out a kind of steady
loss of about eight cents of play so we
would summarize this by saying that you
expect to lose eight cents meaning that
your average loss is eight cents and you
expect it that's gonna be the phenomenon
that comes up if you keep playing the
game repeatedly and repeatedly it's
important to notice of course you never
actually lose eight cents on any single
play so what you excuse notion of you're
expecting to lose eight cents it never
happens it's just your average loss dose
every single player either gonna lose $1
win $1 win $2 win $3 there's no age
sense at all showman showing up okay so
now let's abstract the expected value of
a random variable or so random variables
is this the thing that probabilistically
takes on different values with different
probabilities and it's expected value is
defined to be its average value where
the different values are weighted by
their probabilities we can write this
out as a precise formula the expectation
of a random variable R is defined to be
the sum over all its possible values it
doesn't indicate what the summation is
but that's over all possible values V of
V times the probability that V comes up
the probability that R equals V so this
is the basic definition of the expected
value of a random variable now let me
mention here that this sum works because
since we're assume
countable sample space are is defined on
only countably many outcomes which means
it can only take countably many values
so this is a countable sum over all the
possible values that are takes because
there are only accountably many
countably many other well ok and what
we've just concluded then is the
expected win in the carnival dice game
is minus 17 216 check this formal
definition of the expectation of a
random variable versus the random
variable defined to be how much you win
on a given play of carnival dice and it
comes out to be that average minus 2 set
minus 17 over to 16 now there's a
technical result that's useful in some
proofs and that says that there's
another way to get the expectation the
expectation can also be expressed by
saying it's the sum over all the
possible outcomes in the sample space s
is the sample space of the value of the
random variable at that outcome times
the probability of that outcome yeah so
this is another definite alternative
definition of compared to saying that
it's the the the sum over all the values
times the probability of that value here
it's the sum over all the outcomes of
the the value of the random variable the
outcome times the probability of the
outcome it's not entirely obvious that
those two definitions are equivalent
this form of the definition turns out to
be technically helpful in some proofs
although outside of proofs you don't
don't use it so much in applications but
it's not a bad exercise to prove this
equivalence so I'm going to walk you
through it but if it's boring it's kind
of a boring series of equations on
slides and you're welcome to skip past
it it is a derivation that I expect you
to be able to carry out so let's just
carry out this derivation I'm going to
prove that the expectation is equal to
the sum over all the outcomes of the
value of the random variable at the
outcome times the probability of the
outcome and let's prove it in order to
prove it let's begin with one little
remark that's useful ok remember
this notation R equals V describes the
event that the random variable takes the
value V which by definition is an event
is the set of outcomes where this
property holds so it's the set of
outcomes Omega where R of Omega is equal
to V so let's just remember that that
brackets R equals V is the event that R
is equal to V meaning the set of
outcomes where that's true so what that
tells us in particular is that the
probability of R equals V is by
definition the sum of the probabilities
of the outcomes in the event so it's the
sum over all those outcomes now let's go
back to the original definition of the
expectation of R the original definition
is and the standard one is it's the sum
over all the values of the value times
the weight of the times the probability
that the random variable is equal to the
value now on the previous slide we just
had a formula for the probability that R
is equal to V it's simply the sum over
all the outcomes of where R is where R
is equal to V of the probability of that
outcome so I can replace that term by
the sum over all the outcomes of the
probability of the outcome okay so I'm
trying to head towards an expression
that's only outcomes which is kind of
the top level strategy here so the first
thing I did was I got rid of that
probability of V and replaced it by the
sum of all these probability of the
probabilities of all the outcomes where
are SV well next step is I'm gonna just
distribute the V over the inner sum and
I get that this thing is equal to the
sum of again over all those outcomes in
R equals V of V times the probability of
the outcome but look the out these
outcomes are the outcomes where R is
equal to V so I can replace that v by r
of Omega that one slipped sideways a
little bit so let's watch that this V is
simply going to become an R of Omega
where I'm still summing over the same
set of omegas but now I've gotten
pretty much everything but the Omegas so
I've got this inner sum of over all
possible omegas in R of V of R of Omega
times the probability of Omega and I'm
summing over all possible V but if I'm
summing over all possible V and then all
possible outcomes where R is equal to V
I wind up something over all possible
outcomes and so I finished the proof
that the expectation of R is equal to
the sum over all the outcomes of our
over megha times the probability of
Omega now I'd never do a proof like this
in a lecture because I think watching a
lecturer write stuff on the board and a
whole bunch of symbols and manipulating
equations is really insipid and boring
most people can't follow it anyway I'm
hoping that in the video where you can
go back if you wish and replay it and
watch it more slowly or at your own
speed the derivation will be of some
value to you but let's step back a
little bit and notice some top-level
technical things that we never really
paid attention to in the process of
doing this manipulative proof so the top
level observation first of all is that
this proof like many proofs in basic
foundations of probability theory and
random variables in particular involves
taking sums and rearranging the terms in
the sums a lot so the first question is
why sums remember here we were summing
over all the possible variables all the
possible values of some random variable
why is that a sum well it's the sum
because we were assuming that the sample
space was countable there were only a
countable number of values R of Omega 0
R of Omega 1 R of Omega N and so on and
so we we can be sure that the sum over
all the possible values of the random
variable is a countable some it's a sum
and we don't have to worry about
integrals which is the main technical
reason why we're doing discrete
probability and assuming that there are
only a countable number of outcomes
there's a second very important
technicality that's worth mentioning all
the proofs involved rearranging terms in
sums freely and without care
but that means that we're implicitly
assuming that it's safe to do that and
that in particular that the defining
some four expectations needs to be
absolutely convergent and all of these
sums need to be absolutely convergent in
order for that kind of rearrangement to
make sense so remember that absolute
convergence means that the that the sum
of the absolute values of all the terms
in the sum converge so if we look at
this definition of expectation it said
it was the sum over all the values in
the range we know that's accountable sum
of the value times the probability that
R was equal to that value but the very
definition never specified the order in
which these terms V times probability R
equals being got added up it better not
make a difference so we're implicitly
assuming absolute convergence of this
sum in order for the expectation to even
be well-defined as a matter of fact the
terrible pathology that happens and you
may have learned about this in first
time calculus and we actually have a
problem in the text about it is that you
can have sums like this that are not
absolutely convergent and and then well
you pick your favorite value and I can
rearrange the terms in the sum so that
it converges to that value when you're
dealing with non absolute value sums
rearranging is is a no-no the sum
depends crucially on the order in which
the terms appear and all of the
reasoning in probability theory would be
inapplicable so we are implicitly
assuming that all of these sums are
absolutely convergent well just to get
some vocabulary in place the expected
value is also known as the mean value or
the mean or the expectation of the
random variable now let's connect up
expectations with averages in a more
precise way we said that the expectation
was kind of an abstraction of averages
but it's intimates more intimately
connected to averages than that even
let's take an example we're suppose you
have a pile of graded exams and you pick
one at random
let's let s be the score
of the randomly picked exam so I'm
turning this this process this random
process of picking an exam from the Rev
grape from the pile is defining a random
variable s where by definition of
picking one at random I mean uniformly
so s is actually not a uniform random
variable but I'm picking the exams with
equal probability and then they have
different scores so the outcomes are of
uniform probability but s is not because
there might be a lot of outcomes a lot
of exams of the same score all right s
is a random variable defined by this
process of picking a random exam so and
then you can just check that the
expectation of s now exactly equals the
average exam score which is the typical
thing that students want to know when
the exam is done what's the average
score actually the average score is
often less informative the median score
the middle score but people somehow or
other always want to know about the
averages the reason why the average may
not be so informative is because well it
has some weird properties that are
lowest rate in a second but the the
point here of what we did where we took
on the we got at the average score on
the exam by defining a random variable
based on picking a random exam so that's
a general process we can estimate
averages in some population of things by
estimating the expectations of random
variables based on picking random
elements from the thing that we're
averaging over
that's called sampling and it's a basic
idea of probability theory that we're
going to be able to get a hold of
averages by abstracting the calculation
of an average into taking defining a
random variable and calculating its
expectation let's look at an example
it's obviously impossible for all the
exams to be above average because then
the average would be above average
that's absurd
so if you translate that into a formal
statement about expectations
it translates directly by the way I
don't know how many of you listen to the
Prairie Home Companion but one of the
sign offs there is at the town of Lake
Wobegon in Wisconsin where all the
children are above average well paint
possible that translates into this
technical statement that the probability
that a random variable is greater than
its expected value is less than one it
can't always be greater than its
expected value that's absurd on the
other hand it's actually possible for
the probability that the random variable
is bigger than its expected value to be
as close to one as you want
and one way to think about that is that
for example almost everyone has an above
average number of fingers
think about that for a second almost
everyone has an above average number of
fingers well the explanation is really
simple it's simply because amputation is
much more common than polydactyl ISM and
if you can't understand what I just said
look it up and think about it